hi there so every season I have
something I call my snowboarding go bag
you can use for snowboarding for skiing
and what it is is a bag that's ready to
go whenever someone calls and says hey
it's snowing in the mountains let's get
out of here so the first thing I have is
this pair of really cool oakley goggles
so they have a really cool heads up
display allowed to see how faster going
if you're getting text messages from
your Android or IRS phone that's pretty
cool so in addition some goggles you're
going to want some pants now the pants i
have have gore-tex in because I fall on
my ass a lot I have these Hansen hailey
base layers these are really thin their
light now somebody will say oh you need
a pair of socks no you don't need one
pair of socks you need at least two
pairs of socks I have a couple face
masks now all of my gloves come with
these little liners so you put these on
and then you put your regular gloves on
which is nice get two of these you want
to make sure your your hands and your
feet stay warm everything else can get a
little bit cold but if your hands and
feet get cold at your hose that's into
your day I got some extra gloves but
these really cool gloves i have actually
have a bluetooth headset in them so if
i'm on the slopes someone gives me a
call I'd look ridiculous but I can do
this hello yeah it's kind of ridiculous
but they're really cool to maybe I could
juice
and of course I have my jacket now you
want to want a jacket with a lot of
extra pockets to keep all of your junk
in well pockets on the inside you want
hidden pockets for hiding things like a
scarf or something to lock your
snowboard or skis up when you put it
away a banana for potassium you're going
to get a cramp power bars because who
has time to stop when it's a powder day
bring lots of sunscreen even if it's
overcast you're going to want this plus
sunscreen for your lips ibuprofen take
two of these and you're going to
seriously you just take two at the end
of the day I got some hot hands for
extra extra cold days if you don't have
a helmet that has built in the earphones
these are these earphones from airwave
they just go over your ear they don't go
in your ear so it's nice is they don't
block all the sound it's kind of like
listening to ambient music as opposed to
have them crammed in your ear if you
fall down I have this like fear smashing
it into my brain you can hear the ice
when you're skiing or snowboarding and
you'll be able to hear you know the kid
who's probably doing like 60 miles an
hour past you bring this awesome tool
not because you're going to be doing any
sort of would work or you know fixing
any lips while you're up there but if
your friend is driving and your friends
has let's say a two-wheel drive a car
you're going to have to put chains on
and I would suspect twenty percent of
the time you put chains on it's a huge
pain in the ass and you're going to want
something that's going to help you get
them on if they fall off or do a little
work or whatever you're also going to
want to bring a little tool this is
something that I bring with me it has a
bunch of bits in it this is in case
bolts or nuts come loose on my snowboard
on my skis I can just adjust them really
quickly they also have tools at the top
of the mountains now but if you're in
the middle of a run and you realize that
your binding is coming off this could be
a lifesaver and finally I have a compass
I do a lot of backcountry and trees
snowboarding so this compass is a
lifesaver just in
case so that's it this is just a regular
black duffel bag you want something that
you can squish and throw in the back of
someone's car so that's it that's what I
use when I go snow more yeah that's my
go bag and see on the slopes